han pasado más de 18 meses desde el
asesinato del presidente haitiano
benelmois y ahora el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos dice que ha
acusado a cuatro hombres por el
asesinato James solas y Joseph Vincent
ambos con doble nacionalidad haitiana y
americana así como Alejandro Rivera
ciudadano colombiano han sido acusados
de Conspiración para cometer asesinato
el último sospechosos Christian sano
tiene doble nacionalidad al parecer
quería sustituir a mois y está acusado
de delitos relacionados con el
contrabandonois fue asesinado a tiros el
7 de julio de 2021 en su casa de Puerto
Príncipe por lo que la policía dice que
fue un escuadrón de mercenarios
extranjeros según el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos en un
principio los sospechosos querían
secuestrar a Moisés pero los planes
habrían cambiado
se alega que el 6 de julio de 2021
solash Vincent Rivera y otros se
reunieron en una casa cerca de la
residencia del presidente mois donde se
distribuyeron armas de fuego y equipo y
solash anunció que la misión era matar
al presidente mois
los fiscales dicen que el complot se
urdió originalmente en Florida los
cuatro hombres van a ser juzgados en ese
estado después de que la investigación
haitiana se paralizara con los jueces
recibiendo amenazas de muerte en el
momento del asesinato de Moisés Haití ya
estaba lidiando con varias crisis que
entraron en plena ebullición tras su
asesinato y las bandas se han hecho con
el control de la mayor parte de Puerto
Príncipe